so the Joker kills Batman and blows up
Los Angeles and this is gonna be one of
the coolest stories ever when it comes
to the Joker the ending of this is nuts
and I'm really curious to see how you
guys feel about the ending of this whole
thing so what this does is this
initially picks up basically in Gotham
City right and it says four days ago now
the comic is on a timeline in the sense
that things take place right over the
course of a set period of time it's not
overly important so I wouldn't really
stress about that too much but you've
basically just kind of got like this mob
boss who's eating some food and then
like this guy comes in with his throat
slit just bleeding all over the place
there's like human body parts in the mob
boss's food like ears and stuff like
that but when they get in there what
they end up finding is that like the
Joker and his gang are basically
chopping people up and then putting
pieces of them in the food which is the
most insane in Joker thing ever now
here's where everything gets nuts
because what the Joker does is he
snatches up all these guys right this
mob boss and his henchman and so on and
so forth and then basically brings his
own guys his clown forces if you want to
call him that to meet with like two face
and black mask and Edward Enigma in
these guys right now if you don't know
who like Black Mask or Edward nigma The
Riddler or Two-Face are I don't know
what to tell you because there's some of
the most iconic Batman villains ever but
the long and short of this is that it's
really just the Joker kind of making a
stance the reason why is because the
Joker's been out of the Batman comics
and out of Gotham City for quite some
time he's been gone now a combination of
this comes out of the Batman Joker War
Story which was done by James tinyon as
well as the Joker's own solo series but
the reality here is that with him having
been gone what basically took place here
is the Joker's henchmen only ever went
one of two ways either they joined other
super villain groups or they stayed
loyal to the Joker and they were killed
and so what the Joker is doing is by
showing back up here trying to make this
case that like the Joker's back
everybody needs to listen to me now
here's the thing about this right
two-faced Riddler black mask these guys
they're not worried about the Joker
anymore and there was a time when that
wasn't the case there was a time in
Gotham City where whenever the Joker
showed up whether it was Batman or
anyone somebody else that had to deal
with him they were on some level
terrified of what the Joker was capable
of criminals were more scared of him
than Batman was but everybody shared
some measure of fear because as Kevin
Conroy said in Batman the animated
series The Joker schemes make sense to
nobody but himself and so as he does
this he starts executing these different
guys but because the various villains
here just aren't really buying into a
stick they quite literally run him out
of town they tell him like you've got x
amount of days to get out of Gotham
right because if you decide you want to
stay here we're going to come for you
and we are going to kill you now one of
the crazy things that goes on here is
that there is a guy with a mask on his
head and this guy seems to be of
particular interest because there's a
kind of monologue here where he talks
about how he thought he was going to
survive this and everything was going to
be okay write his team touch and go for
a few seconds and then one of the
henchmen draws attention to the guy in
the mask and of course Joker ends up
shooting that guy and so as the henchman
of the Joker are dumping this guy's body
into the ground he suddenly wakes up
like literally just starts breathing
after getting shot in the face this guy
just starts breathing so of course they
Panic they freak out and they basically
take off now at this point we switch
over to the city of Los Angeles which is
where the Jokers travel to now if you're
not familiar with Joker and Batman
comics it probably seems a little
strange to see this happen this is not
uncommon and in fact back during the
1970s and 1980s in the Joker comics
there was a point where he traveled to
the Middle East so it's not uncommon to
see Joker leaving the city of Gotham and
traveling to different locations nine
times out of ten it's done for the
pursuit of a greater cause which is
rooted in Gotham in this instance he's
basically moving to LA and as he's
talking to one of the guys here one of
the things that he's told is like Los
Angeles is not like Gotham City sure we
have like masks and we've got people who
do crazy and wonky things but we're a
respectable town or at least as
respectable as Hollywood possibly can be
but when the Joker tells them like I
don't want your permission to be here
and I don't want your town I simply want
your office The Joker grabs them and
just throws him out of the building
right he's just like your office belongs
to me now so like that's the end of that
guy now switching over to the man of the
mask one of the things he does is he
travels to Arkham Asylum now this is
kind of a little bit of an important
thing because we'll learn more about
this guy here in a minute but he's
probably one of the most important
characters in the story right so keep
that guy in the back of your head but
from here we jump back to LA and The
Joker literally addresses the entirety
of the country he hijacks the news
Airways across the United States and
just starts broadcasting everywhere and
what he says here is he's like good
evening ladies and gentlemen or good
morning or whatever time of the day it
is for you uh I am the Joker and if you
haven't heard of me well I'm the clown
Prince of Crime in Gotham City and he
talks about how like when he went there
and tried to return the different
villains basically ran him out but they
also helped him to realize that his
brand of Comedy is something that the
rest of the world is missing right the
rest of the country is missing that's
sure the country's divided politically
and socially and so on but the Joker has
the cure for what ails us so he's gonna
bring laughter and joy to everybody
across the United States whether you
want it or not and the funny thing about
this is that like Harley Quinn sees this
Lex Luthor sees this everybody sees
what's going on here and it turns
attention to everybody but the person
that really really focuses on all of
this is Jason Todd now before we get to
him because we'll talk about him here in
a minute he's very important to this
story before we get to him we pick up
with the man in The Mask right now this
guy makes his way to a bar and then he
ends up going to the bathroom in that
bar but once he gets in there there's
this guy who's like shooting up and he's
like dude the bathroom's occupied and
the man of the Mask is like dude not too
worried about that man it looks like
there's two of us in here now that kind
of thing not really taking this
situation seriously so where this guy
who's shooting up goes to try to stab
The Man in The Mask the guy in The Mask
gouges his eyes out of his head and then
takes the knife of the dude who was
shooting up and starts cutting the mask
off of his face only for us to find out
it's the Joker so there's two jokers
running around there's the one in Los
Angeles and then there's the one here I
told you it was gonna get crazy like I
told you the story was going to get nuts
and it only gets better it only gets
better like it just gets ridiculously
good and so at this point we switch over
to Jason Todd who shows up at the bar to
basically investigate the deaths of one
of the people here now for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with this you're
probably asking yourself where's Batman
right isn't Batman the guy who chases
the Joker and under normal circumstances
you would be right it would usually be
Batman but the history between the Joker
and Jason Todd is a very personal
history so back in the 1970s and 80s DC
had a story called death in the family
where literally The Joker killed Jason
Todd he beat him with a crowbar and then
blew him up now of course Jason Todd
ended up returning to life because it's
comic books and that kind of stuff
happens but ever since then Jason Todd
has had a vendetta against the Joker and
has always been trying to kill him it's
one of the big differences between the
Red Hood and Batman Batman believes that
while villains can't always be redeemed
they deserve a chance at that right so
he has his no kill rule Jason Todd
doesn't have that man Jason Todd will
shoot you on the spot ask no questions
and leave like that's literally what he
is man he's like The Punisher of the
Batman family it's pretty amazing but
following that of course the Joker ends
up basically putting on a kind of
makeshift outfit for himself a hood that
kind of thing to keep his identity
secret he doesn't want anybody to know
who he is and he's just sort of making
his way around the city of Gotham now
he'll be doing that for a little while
uh we'll kind of see him intermittently
over the course of this but by and large
a lot of The Story begins to shift over
in the direction of what's basically Red
Hood hunting for the joker as well as
the fake Joker who's in the city of Los
Angeles and so one of the things that
happens is that with this Joker that's
out there right presumably the fake
Joker that when he's out there one of
his guys starts talking to him about
what's going on in Gotham City and where
this Joker's like what are you talking
about his response is there's a Joker in
Gotham City who's running around and
just killed a guy like a day or two ago
so it looks like there's two of you out
there now the Hollywood Joker we'll call
him Joker too Joker two is just kind of
like uh all right here's the thing man
are you telling me that I'm not really
the Joker is that really the argument
that you're making here and for the most
part his henchmen know well enough to
know not to challenge him but of course
the the line's been crossed and the
Joker helps this guy finish with all his
living by pushing his head into a fish
tank and then shooting him in the back
of the head and like that said he just
kills him on the spot and so Joker won
that's the one that we'll call the man
who was previously in the mask that
joker one ends up meeting with a guy
named Cardiff now Cardiff was at one
point one of his top henchmen but of
course Carter spills the beans and says
after you were gone all the different
henchmen again either sided with you
staying loyal and were killed or they
joined different villains from across
the landscape but whatever the case is
the numbers that you had at your side
are completely and totally dwindled
there really isn't anybody else left
here and so Cardiff basically extends a
kind of Olive Branch by saying you know
feel free to peruse the closet and throw
some clothes on and that kind of a thing
and so what he does it switches over to
one of the henchmen who saw everything
popping off with Joker one and then of
course he's filling the beans to the
forces of the Riddler and that's when
Jason Todd shows up and says like no
one's seen the Joker since he took off
to La this guy's saying that he's seen a
joker here these things aren't adding up
Let the guy I talk now of course red
Hood's not necessarily welcome here so
they initially attack him and then of
course Red Hood helps them understand
their place in the bigger picture and
starts beating the crap out of all of
them but the other thing about this is
that joker one ends up traveling to meet
Harley Quinn now can we all just admit
how amazing it is that when Harley Quinn
answers the door she's got like this
whole Supergirl get up and the first
thing she does is just like beat Joker
one over the head with a baseball bat
and then as soon as this guy's
unconscious she basically ties him up
now this is when things start to get
murky because up to this point we could
make a legitimate case that joker won is
the real Joker in Gotham and Joker 2 in
Los Angeles is the fake Joker but this
is where Harley Quinn and even Matthew
Rosenberg who's writing the story this
is when they start to throw a wrench in
the works because one of the things that
happens is that as Joker one is talking
to Harley Quinn Harley Quinn starts
calling him out and she basically says
like you're not the Joker I don't know
why you're dressed up like The Joker but
you are not the Joker and when he asked
the question he says why are you saying
that she says because the Joker would
never come and see me that would never
ever ever happen the Joker mistreated me
he hated me right he seemed to love me
he was a psychopath right his emotions
were all over the place plus you've got
a gunshot in the head and that just
seems a little strange so the result of
this is that she actually lets him go
right and he ends up just kind of going
back out there and it seems really based
more on pity than anything else because
if he was the real Joker Harley Quinn
never would have let him go in that way
and that's where things get kind of
funny because even Joker won himself
kind of comes to this question that he
has am I really not the Joker like am I
not the actual Joker and so it's really
fun in terms of how this is being played
as far as head games go because for
those of you guys who are familiar with
Joker Mythos in the last few years one
of the stories that we got was called
three Jokers but it wasn't like this it
was just three different versions of the
Joker and each one had their own
personality and they all actually more
or less operated together in this
instance you've got a couple different
Jokers running around and each one of
them believes that they're the real
Joker so that's where things get really
fun here now at this point Red Hood
catches up to the Joker and this is one
of the biggest faults of Jason Todd as a
character so for those of you guys who
are familiar with Batman one of the
things you guys know is Batman is very
methodical he thinks a lot he processes
a lot of things he's not Reckless he
doesn't just jump in and start doing
things Jason Todd is in a lot of ways
the opposite and he kind of always has
been he's always been Reckless and so
when he confronts The Joker instead of
just killing him on the spot he
literally starts talking to the Joker
and the Joker starts talking to him he's
kind of savoring the moment where he
finally has the upper hand on the Joker
himself and can basically kill him the
downside of this is that Jokers uses the
opportunity to jump off what is
basically a scaffold and then lands in
the water now where Harley Quinn
dismisses it and says one that's not the
real Joker and two that guy's probably
dead Jason Todd has to know he has to
know whether or not it's the actual
Joker and he has to know whether or not
he's actually dead and so at that point
Joker 1 wakes up in Gotham City river
right like literally like emerges from
the river there's a couple of homeless
guys there he probably kills one of them
and then takes their coat because he
makes a comment on how nice their coat
is that's one of the things about The
Joker Is that he'll be like man that's a
really nice coat and then it'll cut to a
different scene and then he's wearing
the coat so he most likely killed the
guy but Joker one shows up at Gotham
General now when he shows up here with
the hood over his head and the homeless
man's cloak and so on he looks like a
vagrant so it's very easy for everybody
to just kind of overlook him and not
take him seriously but he ends up
basically taking one of the bodies
that's basically a dead woman and then
takes the doctor with him and drags them
into the room Reveals His identity to
the doctor and then starts talking about
how he thinks he's poisoned right he was
poison and he's not feeling very good
that kind of a thing and the doctor kind
of runs over these symptoms albeit in a
state of high duress right like are you
vomiting and all that kind of stuff
please don't kill me so on and so forth
and so the Joker's like no I mean I
don't have any trouble breathing I'm not
really vomiting consistently or anything
like that you know and the result of the
doctor is like well then I doubt that
you're poisoned right there must be
something else going on so then the
Joker kind of makes this statement well
then either you need to figure it out
and give me some anti-poison Hills or
something or I'm going to blow this
whole place up with a bog right like
that kind of a thing and because no one
ever really knows for sure whether or
not the Joker's telling the truth no
one's stupid enough to question it so
the doctor basically goes along with it
and literally Joker pops these things
that says I hope they work and he's like
I still have this crazy headache and the
doctor's like well it might be caused by
something else and the Joker's like well
it's probably this gunshot in my head
right this bullet in my head so of
course following that literally the
doctor ends up performing makeshift
surgery on the Joker in this place by
essentially removing the bullet and then
like bandaging him up in the whole nine
yards and so following that the Joker
basically ends up like trying to find a
way out of the hospital the problem is
that the cops were alerted to the
Joker's presence when he was here and so
the cops are like surrounding the place
Red Hood shows up on the scene and so
seemingly there's no way out of here he
ends up just trying to make his way
through the hospital in order to find
some alternate route of Escape now the
funny thing about this is that because
he looks like he's dressed up like the
doctor he's being approached by nurses
and stuff and then of course basically
takes off but ends up in a room full of
these dying kits right these sick kits
and I wouldn't go as far as to say that
you get a super touching moment with the
joker the Joker's never really been
sentimental unless he's reliving these
moments that he considers to be
beautiful when he was like beating Jason
Todd to death or something along those
lines and in fact his physical
appearance scares the crap out of these
kids but what's so funny about this is
that he's able to kind of relate to them
on a personal level where he kind of
starts telling the story about how he
basically came back only to find out
that somebody had stolen his identity
and that kind of a thing it's all from
his perspective it's all from this idea
that like Joker 2 out in La is not the
real Joker that this guy Joker one is
the absolute Joker he genuinely believes
that he's the Joker that's the irony
here though because Joker 2 believes
he's the real Joker so it's kind of like
which one is the real one right which
one is which like I said the inning of
this is going to absolutely blow your
mind and so what goes on here is that
where he's relating to these kids and
really even able to gain their trust to
a degree by trying to be funny and
cracking some jokes and different things
like that when one of the cops comes
barging into the room and asks them have
you seen a guy who's got like really
pale skin and he's got some crazy
looking eyes a horrifying smile green
hair the response to the kids is like we
haven't really seen anybody like that
here uh can you change me because I made
a mess and of course the cop ends up
leaving and so as the Joker leaves he
gives these kids these parting words of
wisdom where he says by the way kids get
some new toys right parents never say no
to a dying child which if I'm being
honest with you it's probably one of the
darkest comments that I've ever heard
the Joker make and I know it doesn't
seem that way but it's like parents who
go through this kind of thing it is
incredibly traumatizing and parents just
want to spend as much time with their
kids as they can and they want their
kids to be happy but the Joker to a
degree just kind of giving these kids
advice and saying like just get better
choice from your parents right they're
not going to say no it's just kind of
dark I don't know why but it just feels
really really dark but in the midst of
all this of course the Joker ends up
taking out one of the cops by helping
him finish with all his living and then
Dawn's costume now that's one of the
things that I hope you notice about this
is the Joker's a lot more intelligent
than people give him credit for it but I
think a lot of that is because the
nature of the Joker's stories is that
oftentimes they involve him doing these
crazy obnoxious schemes like trying to
copyright fish but when you break the
Joker down and you look at the kind of
stunts he's pulled off the level of
intelligence and Ingenuity necessary to
do that is pretty insane and so of
course as the Joker is trying to make
his way out being dressed as a cop he
suddenly met by Red Hood and he
immediately books it now of course he
ends up basically stumbling into a room
there's another cop in there this cop
does not know the other cop is the Joker
in Disguise so when Jason Todd comes
running up the cop tells him lower your
gun and in that momentary distraction
Joker one pulls a gun on this cop and
then uses him as a hostage in order to
get away from Jason Todd so you've got
this kind of like eking along situation
where the Joker's like slowly walking
backward with this hostage and Jason
Todd is slowly like following him with a
gun pointed at him but he ultimately
tells him get rid of the gun or I'm
gonna kill this guy on the spot now this
is this is one of those moments with
Jason Todd where I'm not exactly sure
how I feel because with like a story
like under the Red Hood when Jason Todd
first came back and he was very much the
Vigilante taking over the criminal
underworld kind of character he wouldn't
have cared he would have shot the Joker
and if this cop happened to be killed
when the Joker died and his body
reflexed and pulled the trigger well you
know that happens sometimes right you
can't make an omelet without breaking a
few eggs that was his philosophy and
whether it's because Jason Todd has been
spending time with Batman whatever the
case happens to be that he ultimately
ends up throwing his gun away and this
gives the Joker the chance to get away
now at this point we transition over to
one of the coolest moments in the story
when the Joker busts into what used to
be one of his safe houses which is now
occupied by Jervis touch right also
known as the Mad Hatter in DC Comics you
could also call him service tech people
call him that as well but basically
because it was one of the Joker's safe
houses when he does bust in here he's
dressed up like Batman which is kind of
amazing and I'm not gonna lie to you
guys I really hope people dress up this
way at Comic Cons like they cost play as
like Joker Batman I don't know what you
would call him what would you call them
leave a comment down below and tell me
what would you call this version of
Batman that the Joker's pretending to be
but regardless what he says is like this
used to be one of his safe houses so
what he wants to know is how Jervis
found this place in the first place and
what Jervis tells him is that Joker 2
gave it to him and that he's back in
Gotham and he's not happy with Joker one
right that like literally he's basically
saying you are not the real Joker and
the real Jokers here and the real
Joker's pissed so again it's a really
really cool moment and so at this point
this story comes to its head right where
basically Joker one meets Joker too that
with Joker one being told by Jervis that
Joker 2 is in Gotham City Joker one is
able to track him down and he shows up
basically dressed as a fireman now the
fact that he's dressed in just a
ridiculous outfit had really just kind
of all but tells us this is the real
Joker and even just the exchange between
the two right Joker one showing up here
like literally he's just like so you're
going to tell me what I want to know and
you're going to tell me why you're
impersonating me why you're pretending
to be me the Joker 2 is like I mean it's
going to be kind of a hard sell to get
me to give you that information when
you're literally locked in an elevator
and you've got nothing but a water gun
in your hands but then you start
sniffing the air and he's like what in
the heck is that smell and the response
to Joker one is oh yeah I set the
building on fire on my way up that right
there tells us it's the real Joker I
mean that right there like just that
tells us it's the actual Joker because
it's something the real Joker would do
it's absolutely something the actual
Joker would do set the building on fire
so both of them are going to burn alive
and then take the elevator up so there's
presumably no real way out of here and
so that's when Joker two is like you're
absolutely insane so as the two of them
have this conversation the whole guys of
Joker 2 begins to falter it begins to
drop off and it's not really the Joker
at all it's just a person masquerading
as the Joker all pretense is gone and so
ultimately what ends up happening here
is that as the two of them are
confronting one another that what goes
on is Joker one ends up basically
pulling out his water gun and then
spraying Joker 2 in the face only for us
to find out that it's not water it's
acid and he literally says just because
it's a water gun doesn't mean you can't
put other things inside of it other
liquids which is kind of a crazy idea
and so Joker 2 literally just like flees
just runs as fast as he can jumps out of
the building and ends up making his
escape and so Joker 1 ends up using the
pistol and then spraying the locks on
the elevator and then basically making
his escape and so with Joker 2 basically
descending down into the sewers Joker
one follows him and when Joker one finds
Joker too he's literally just leaned
against the wall terrified for his life
right absolutely horrified and he's like
I didn't sign up for any of this right
so this guy's been hired by somebody but
he's like I didn't sign up for any of
this this is not what I wanted to be a
part of and none of this was the bargain
and he even goes so far as to reveal who
it was that he was hired by only for him
to be shot and killed by Red Hood Red
Hood literally just like runs up on the
drain and just fires the shot off on
Joker and kills him on the spot and so
at that point Joker 1 ends up fleeing
but the problem is that when the cops
get down into the subway system Joker
2's nowhere to be found he's gone and
Joker one didn't take him anywhere so
basically Joker 2's not dead which
really begs the question how is it
possible that Joker 2 could be shot in
the eye like in the face how's that
possible he could be shot in the face
and he could survive well this is where
the ending comes that absolutely blows
things away so what ends up happening
here is we transitioned to Malibu
California and you have a phone call
between the Joker and the person who is
portraying Joker 2 which turns out to be
no one other than Clayface and I was
just like what like as soon as I saw
that I was like no way that's the case
like that's crazy and so because of that
like the the beans are spilled this is
the guy who was pretending to be Joker
too and so what this means is there's
like three Jokers running around right
Joker one was the guy that had had a
bullet in his head that had surgery done
on him by the doctor right the guy who
was originally in The Mask Joker 2 is
basically Clayface who was pretending to
be the Joker and then took off out to LA
saying he was going to quote unquote fix
the world and then there's like Joker 3
right who's this Joker here in Malibu
here's the twist here's the kicker to
all of this right this Joker who's in
Malibu this is the one that actually
showed up this is the actual Joker too
this is the one that showed up in LA and
said he was going to fix the country
that he was going to make everything
better again that Two-Face showing up in
the city of Gotham was done by Joker in
Malibu right like that was literally
orchestrated by him his instruction was
there is a joker right Joker one there's
a joker running around the city of
Gotham pretending to be me you are going
to pretend to be me in the city of
Gotham and you're gonna weed this guy
out I'm going to stay here in the city
of Los Angeles and I'm going to quote
unquote make the country better and so
that's the crazy thing is because now
we've basically only got two jokers
again right so we can kind of revert
back to Joker one and Joker 2 because
that's all we really have but Joker one
we're not we don't see him again right
at least not not within this video Joker
2 is the one that we want to focus on
because as he's in La the entirety of
Los Angeles just rejected him right I
mean they were like we don't want to
have you around here like that's
ridiculous you have no role to play in
here at all and so what he got so
frustrated about is that because of the
fact that the city of Los Angeles
seemingly rejected him at every turn his
ultimate goal is to go back to Gotham
weed out Joker one destroy that guy once
and for all but before he does he has a
parting gift for the city of La he
literally just starts shooting up police
precincts blowing them apart I mean just
Mayhem right just killing people all
over the place and then one of the
things that ends up happening because
cops are looking for him everywhere I
mean literally this guy just blows up
Los Angeles is basically what it does
and so as he's trying to like make his
escape and like the cops are all hunting
for him and everything he's kind of
sneaking along and then he ends up
coming across what he thinks is Batman
right like he's just kind of there and
Batman's like what are you doing here
right and then he realizes it's not an
actual Batman it's one of the people who
dress up and pretend to be Batman in
order to get like pictures taken and
stuff like that in downtown L.A out in
front of the Chinese Theater and so
because of that like this guy's like
here's what's gonna happen if you're
gonna you're gonna operate on my turf
and we're gonna get pictures together
we're doing a 70 30 Revenue split I take
70 of all the money you make right like
literally it's a Shakedown right it's
like like and here's a question I have
is that how it works out there is that
how things get done out there I've
always been kind of curious about that
but what ends up happening is like in
the middle of all that there's like this
couple who comes along and they're like
hey can you take a picture with us right
like can we can we do a picture and
initially they asked for Spider-Man
instead of the Joker
and like literally Batman's like well
Spider-Man's in rehab so of course they
basically can't have a picture with
Spider-Man you end up getting him with
the joker but the Joker's kind of
confused and baffled about everything
that's going on and so the husband's
just kind of like I mean the Joker looks
a little weird here right the clown
looks strange can you make it look like
he's actually fighting like you know
there's an actual conflict going on and
the Joker's like yeah how about this and
he pulls a gun and puts it to the head
of the fake Batman so the fake Batman is
scared out of his wits so the picture
gets taken and then Joker blows the
Batman's head off like literally blows
his head off and is just kind of like
well that was fun that was great you
know you guys have a lovely vacation uh
enjoy yourselves make sure you have a
good time and uh I will catch you later
but in the middle of all this before he
can make his Escape he suddenly set upon
by a character he's never seen before
simply refers to her as a strange lady
in red but before we give you an
explanation about her we're bringing
this video to an end thank you guys for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments section and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]